left to rot we don't know how long the
body of this man has been in these woods
his fingers have been eaten by stray
dogs
as ukrainian soldiers fan through these
words they're not only looking for minds
but every time they come across a body
they'll search it first for any
potential booby traps before looking for
any form of id that might be able to
identify the body
the search of this area of buja is only
just beginning and there may be more
bodies to find
this is a children's summer camp
friendships were forged here memories
made the v marks the russian military
takeover
it's now a place of nightmares
when bucho was retaken on the 31st of
march five bodies were discovered in the
basement of the compound
those who found them say they were
allegedly tied up and executed
pools of blood remain the only sign of
what happened here
tatiana was in her home when the
russians arrived
the russians took everything they could
it's horrible it's horrible i never
thought this could happen to us our
people suffered a lot
and this is the street she lives on
ukrainian authorities are surveying the
damage
butcher is now under ukrainian military
control everywhere you look soldiers are
patrolling while evidence is gathered
for any potential war crimes
investigations
all right imran khan joins us now live
from kiev so clearly from that report
imran you've been to some of these areas
which are really the center of global
attention right now give us a feeling of
what it was like to be there and and how
common are these disturbing images that
we we are seeing
well almost every day they're uncovering
more and more bodies being found in
various different places it wasn't just
the mass grave that we saw uh the other
day wasn't just in this park
that we saw today when we were actually
at the location they were discovering
bodies and
the town has now been taken over by the
military the military announced going in
and sweeping they're going house to
house they're now recording as much as
they can of the destruction and of the
bodies they're finding but we were there
two days ago and the atmosphere was very
different
on
wednesday it was
a lot darker it was a lot more nervy
people were jumpy the military were had
tanks inside uh butcher itself a heavy
security presence the more bodies that
they're finding the more atrocities that
the ukrainians say the russians
committed that they're uncovering the
more people are beginning to realize
that
something really bad happened here now
they need to turn that into legal terms
they need to have an investigation that
proves that the russians
did commit atrocities did commit war
crimes that's the focus now we heard
vladimir zelinski the president talked
at the united nations just 24 hours ago
very strong comments
not just about the russians and
atrocities that they committed but or
allegedly committed but about the u.n
security council itself the russians for
their part uh are saying that they
didn't do any of this that it was all
staged according to one comment by
sergey lavrov the russian foreign
minister but sami there's a very marked
very different atmosphere now as more
things come to light
all right thanks so much that's imran
khan for us there in kiev